let's go to our caller from the 4-1-9
area code who's calling today from 4-1-9
hello david is this me yes it is
uh hello i've called him before i am
from rural ohio
and so my question today is how do you
argue
for a tap for no tax cuts for the rich
with republicans because i've tried this
in the past
and it hasn't worked so their argument
in the past has been
well you see if you tax them then their
businesses are going to go away
and they made all that money legally
they did it
because they just worked harder than
everybody else which isn't true
so i tried arguing with them about it
saying how
these tax tax cuts if you tax them you
could
put it towards infrastructure medicare
and overall
improving the quality of life for your
country and they just straight up refuse
it so my question
for you is how do you argue well one of
the things you have to do
is you have to really separate the
arguments because
even right there you gave me two
different arguments and you kind of
blended them together and you said
i'm having a hard time arguing against
this the first one was
that if you tax you're going to
hurt the businesses or take they'll stop
doing it they'll stop working or
sometimes it extends to they'll move to
another country or whatever the case may
be you'll disincentivize
work or whatever that's one argument
then you went on to
trying to justify the reason we have
taxes as necessary to pay for things and
to have
roads and public schools and whatever
else so
one really important it's impossible to
go through every counterpoint point and
counterpoint here with you
but one thing you really want to do is
you want to separate
out the different arguments and make
them really justify it so
to pick one there's this idea that if
the tax goes
too high they'll they'll just stop their
business it's a disincentive to keep
working because too much of their money
will be going to taxes okay we can we
can deal with that there's a lot of
scholarship on that
and um we can start to talk about
well the devil is in the details what
should the top marginal tax rate be what
we have generally found is
that the the tax the top marginal tax
rate
at which the government maximizes
revenue is around
70 percent now that doesn't mean you get
taxed
70 on all your income that might mean
like
once you get to 10 million a year in
income you start paying
70 or something like that and all of the
scholarship
on it suggests that that does not create
a disincentive
to work and that the truth is if it
started to create one at that point
maybe it wouldn't be altogether a bad
thing so
that's just an example of how you've got
to separate these arguments and not
allow
what gets difficult is you'll have three
or four different arguments that are
sort of related but not really thrown at
you and then you're in the position of
having to pick them apart and respond to
each of them all
all together don't allow that take
control of the narrative
and go point by point and obviously it
takes time to do it so you've got to
have some patience
yeah because i feel like the main
problem with trying to argue this
with republicans like my friends for
example is i mean they respect my
opinion they they listen to me
it's just their parents have grown them
up in a way
that they already have their hard set
beliefs
yes and nothing will change their mind
right i've just learned to accept this
fact
yep so what you have to do in those
cases is
recognizing that is important you're not
going to change their minds by beating
them over the head
get them to justify their beliefs deeply
with a sort of socratic method of
questioning and one place on taxes you
can start is okay listen
do you want to get get the crazies out
of the conversation by saying
are our taxes legal and should we have
some taxes
okay that's the first place if someone
says taxes are
theft or slavery and are illegal or the
tax rate should be zero
i wouldn't even waste my time with those
people that's not
it's just it's go do something else go
read a book you're gonna have some some
better thing you can focus on once they
concede
okay yeah midway through my argument
i realized this and i tried changing the
topic
to something else i forgot what it was
yeah they started
they started coming after me saying how
i'm i'm against
billionaires and how just because they
work so much harder
than i do that i shouldn't be jealous of
them which i'm not jealous
they made their money through illegal
ways
money laundering such like the trump
campaign 170 dollars
of money laundering oh you know what i'm
so i now i'm starting to see why maybe
these conversations aren't going so well
i'm you're you're sort of all over the
place because now you're on to
talking about individual billionaires
who are accused of
but that's a very different conversation
from taxation and what the tax rate
would be so what i what i would
really do is don't don't go all over the
place with arguments about money
laundering and should billion
you you've really got to narrow the
conversation find
two or three really good arguments and
come prepared because i can
i can see you're probably getting
flustered and going all over the place
i didn't i didn't bring that up okay i
was still staying on the main taxes how
you know taxes pay for everything you
need taxes like
in life there's two certain things death
and taxes well but they would argue that
the taxes shouldn't be certain so
this is where i would start i i would
start
i would start with an example i gave you
our taxes okay it sounds like i'm i may
be on speaker and we're starting to echo
you've got a lot going on there and a
lot to contend with but i would really
first focus in on do they concede that
we need
some taxes and that taxes are legal and
then you can work from there in the gray
area
and narrow the focus onto what what the
tax rates should be
all right my friend i appreciate the
phone call sounds like you've got a real
that's a real matzo ball hanging out
there in terms of some of these uh some
of these arguments you're in
uh and i very much wish you the best all
right that does it for me today
as far as phone calls are concerned i
will take more calls again
in the future not today not today but in
the future
and i as always i feel terribly that i
wasn't able to get to everybody who
called in